with all the government and pandemic
changes happening around the world we
checked in with mc law group to learn
more about
immigration law during this time take a
look
so nice to see you you are from mc law
group and we're talking immigration
right a lot going on in the world
it's very nice to be here and yes a lot
is going on
so how has cobit affected immigration
well kovite affected everything
and in industries like tourism
and businesses that have cross-border
all affected and so immigration is the
business that allows people to come to
the united states and obviously it's
been affected tremendously
there's been closures in the uscis and
the consulates as well
and speaking of consulates are they
actually back open overseas or what's
going on with that
so in march most of the consulates
closed and then they slowly started to
reopen
and by june we have many consulates open
but by august a lot started to close up
again
and now we are seeing most of the
consulates are
either rescheduling their interviews or
closing completely
okay and what about people who are
visiting the united states but can't go
back home because of covet
i know that yeah that's gotta be tough
we see that a lot in march a lot of
people got stranded in the u.s
and there's two categories one that are
here on non-immigrant visas
and those individuals were able to apply
for their extensions
people who applied back in april and me
are now scheduled in their
uh fingerprints and are getting their
approval notices
those that are here on visa waiver from
most european countries in canada
were allowed to apply to uscis to
receive what's called
uh satisfactory departure but it's only
given for 30 days
at a time so if people are still here
and they were
here on a non immigrant visa waiver
program
they should leave because their
extensions already all run out
wow and and this question is really
important what about the daca
individuals
with daca individuals there's been a
roller coaster there's been policies
that came into place
and those policies been stopped by
federal judges
so right now individuals that are ready
to renew their application
should submit their applications but
make sure it is within 150 days of your
expiration
and those individuals who want to
process their
new applications would have to wait for
the policies
by uscis to come out but with a new
administration i think that's going to
happen
okay well we are certainly going to keep
up with mc law group and of course
people should call you
if they have any questions this is
really important information
absolutely for more information call
702-258-1093 or just visit
immigrationlawmb.com we'll be right back